you've gotten llama into tiny grad
you've gotten stable diffusion in
Italian grind what was that like can you
comment on like what are
um what are these models what's
interesting about boarding them so
what's yeah like what what are the the
challenges what is what's naturally
what's easy all that kind of stuff
there's a really simple way to get these
models into tiny grad and you can just
export them as Onyx and then tiny grad
can run onyx
um so the ports that I did of llama
stable diffusion and now whisper are
more academic to teach me about the
models but they are cleaner than the pie
charge versions you can read the code I
think the code is easier to read it's
less lines there's just a few things
about the way tiny grud writes things
here's here's a complaint I have about
pytorch
nn.relu is a class
right so when you create it when you
create an end module you'll put your nn
relues
as in a net and this makes no sense
really use completely stateless
why should that be a class
but that's more like a software
engineering thing oh do you think it has
a cost on performance oh no it doesn't
have a Custom Performance
um but yeah no I think that it it's
that's what I mean about like tiny
grad's front end to being cleaner I see
uh what do you think about Mojo I don't
know if you've been paying attention to
the programming language that does
um some interesting ideas that kind of
intersect uh tiny grad I think that
there's a spectrum and like on one side
you have Mojo and on the other side you
have like ggml
um gml is this like we're going to run
llama fast on Mac and okay we're going
to expand out to a little bit but we're
going to basically like depth first
right Mojo is like we're gonna go breath
first we're going to go so wide that
we're gonna make all of python fast and
Tiny grads in the middle
we are going to make neural networks
fast
yeah but they uh they try to really get
it to be fast compiled down to specifics
uh hardware and make that compilation
step
as flexible and resilient as possible
yeah but they've turned completeness
and that limits you
turn that's what you're saying it's
somewhere in the middle so you're
actually going to be targeting some
accelerators some
like some some number not one my goal is
step one build an equally performance
stack to pie torch on Nvidia and AMD but
with way less lines and then step two is
okay how do we make an accelerator right
but you need step one you have to first
build the framework before you can build
the accelerator uh can you explain ml
perf
uh what's your approach in general to
benchmarking tiny grad performance
so I'm much more of a like
build it the right way and worry about
performance later
um there's a bunch of things where I
haven't even like really dove into
performance the only place where tiny
grad is competitive performance wise
right now is on Qualcomm gpus so tiny
grid is actually used in open pilot to
run the model so the driving model is is
time to grad when did that happen that
transition
eight months ago now
um and it's 2x faster than qualcomm's
Library
what's the hardware of open uh that open
pilot runs on the the kamea it's a
Snapdragon 845
okay so this is using the GPU so the GPU
is an adreno GPU there's like different
things there's like really good
Microsoft paper that talks about like
mobile gpus and why they're different
from desktop gpus
um one of the big things is in a desktop
GPU you can use buffers uh on a mobile
GPU image textures are a lot faster
and a mobile GP image textures and limit
okay
and so you want to be able to leverage
that I want to be able to leverage it in
a way that it's completely generic right
so there's a lot of this xiaomi has a
pretty good open source library for
mobile gpus called mace where they can
generate where they have these kernels
but they're all hand coded right so
that's great if you're doing three by
three comps that's great if you're doing
dense map malls but the minute you go
off the beaten path a tiny bit
well your performance is nothing